yes what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so welcome to our first
trading games organized on discord so
i'm gonna here remind you guys the rules
that we're having we already have some
players so we're gonna go through every
player's plays and analyze why they
decided to take this kind of positions
so i'm gonna show you here everything
we're gonna keep a ranking of the best
players and i'm gonna announce in this
video the prices that will be
distributed every month to the best
players let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so the very first thing for
those who are not with me on this code i
will explain for the first time that we
organize some trading games
so the purpose of those games it's of
course in the simulation mode i will be
taking care of aggregating everybody's
position every player's position
we created a very user-friendly form
that you guys need to feel i will show
you in this video how to do it very
quickly
i'm gonna go through the rules again
with you so that you understand what you
are supposed to do here and we already
have some players so i computed already
the p l of those players so i'm gonna
show you those plays that look pretty
good to me and we're gonna see who is uh
leading the ranking so let's start first
with the uh form so for those who are
with me on discord you go to trading
games you just click on the form guys
it's very easy just here and i'm gonna
show you how to fill it first because
i've received many plays that were not
easy for me to understand and to use so
it was pretty much a pen in the ass
so basically you first give me your
discord id so i know who you are you can
give me a nickname so that you know it's
just more friendly i can call you by
your name or your nickname instead of
your discord id you can add a picture if
you want then
i would be able to understand better
what kind of place you are doing
enter a ticker so we only accept stocks
some of you guys gave us some
cryptocurrency i'm using bloomberg uh to
compute the piano so i'm just not able
to do it for crypto only bitcoin would
be accepted so if you want to play
bitcoin you can enter btc usd here then
you decide if it's a long position or
short position right very easy you give
me your entry level so only one level
some of you gave me many levels guys
it's not gonna be easy for me to do
like that so give me only one level uh
one exit level and one stop loss you
don't need to give me exit level if you
don't have a target you can just let it
run you don't need to give me a stop
loss if you are fine losing all your
capital then you uh
you tell me the reasons why you got in
if you know if you don't know it's fine
just give me no reason it's not
mandatory for example a breakout a
divergence uh you know i'm gonna do it
for example with you tesla
so my nickname is andrew
okay it's called id
andrew
hashtag blah blah blah okay seeker tesla
long okay i buy if you want to buy at
market so basically you can
i want to make things as easy as
possible for you guys so you can just
send me your place whenever you want
during the week i will just take care of
those that are valid those are not
they're not valid and then we're gonna
um so the game would last for one full
month and prices will be given to
players that are the best after one
month
so you can basically have one play a
week or something like this i will
decide i will let you know exactly how
we what are the rules for that for now
don't bother yourself with that if you
have any plays you want to do just go
there whenever you want and fill in the
form so unique entry level if you want
to buy at market you just put something
that you show to be executed so if i buy
tesla at 1000 100
at the open today i would be executed
all right and i have a target at 1500
for example stop loss i don't feel good
if i see a price coming below 990 for
example we have a sma breakout new high
no divergence the volume is huge
company news and nice consumer okay so
this is the reason order signal i like
tesla
okay
do you agree to disclose yes okay and
then i just did i enter everything all
right so you see guys pretty easy just
here give me a real ticker and the
levels don't
give me many levels just give me one
number all right that's
so that i can
easily compute uh every thing that you
give me giving me here you submit and
all right it has been recorded so now
i'm gonna tell you guys uh what are
gonna be the prices so for now we only
have four players all right we had more
than that uh so the games started last
week so we have more players than that
but most of the plays were not i didn't
understand what you guys wanted to do so
just do it again it's going to be
accepted until the end of the month so
you have time
for now i have four valid plays i'm
gonna go through all of those four but
first i'm gonna i want to tell you guys
the prices that will be given for this
month as as we have just started and as
you can see we have only four players i
can't give two big prices i will just
give 300 us dollars to the first player
so right now it is changed so we're
going to analyze his play very soon so
he's making very little profit 30 beeps
you know up on three percent here is the
piano but he's still positive and he's
the first so we're gonna analyze his
play but for now chong is chance sorry
is to receive 300 us dollars by the end
of the month paypal uh transfer with
email address if this is working and
yeah so let's now analyze what he gave
us so kr he wanted to buy at 40
he has a stop loss at 38 and a target at
45. okay
so let's see this place so kr alright so
here it is and what kind of signal is he
seeing he's seeing a sloping breakout a
moving average breakout and a divergence
so let's analyze that all right so i'm
trying to look for those signals
let me get rid of that this is
old stuff all right
so a sloping breakout yes i see it it's
here well done changs you spotted it
okay so we have indeed a sloping
breakout then divergence i'm checking
the macd and indeed i have here the
price action making lower lows and the
momentum indicator making higher lows
all right so this is the divergence on
the daily timeframe and this is
signaling that the bells are out of
steam and that a reversal is about to
come so whenever you have a divergence
plus a breakout which changes identified
you have uh something bullish he also
said uh moving average breakout true
will we just uh broke above the 20
period moving average that was acting as
a resistance so this is a very good play
and i mean i'm happy to see that for now
the number one of the ranking of the uh
the ranking is
giving me a play with good reasons so
and his target is at 45.
45 is a nice target guys okay so what is
he using uh full of sense is the recent
low and he did he's like the
just above the gap down we had here so
it's it's a good target it's a nice
trade and the stop loss at 38 so i guess
you just use the recent low
very good below the 200 day moving
average very well done so this is a very
valid play let's see if he's able to
exit at his target before being stopped
i'm gonna monitor all of that but for
now he's in the money uh his play is
nice once again the game will end at the
end of the month but for next month if
the play is still good we're gonna keep
it and it's gonna be valid for the whole
month and you can add more plays all
right whenever you want and i'm gonna
limit i think five plays maximum by each
player
or something like this so just don't
bother yourself with that i'm gonna take
care of this and i'm gonna announce uh
more rules if needed so very nice play
let's analyze the second one g-star cvs
all right so he's up as well so he's
number two of the ranking for now so
unfortunately there was no prize for
number two so let's see if he's able to
beat chunks before the end of the week i
mean the end of the month which is the
same for this week cvs okay so he's a
buyer at 88. stopped plus 86 target 91
let's check and then we're gonna check
uh the different uh signals
so 88
so he's down all right he's a buyer at
88 he's done so here i put the entries
so those guys that they have all been
executed one has been stopped we're
gonna discuss this no one reached the
target so just focus on uh here guys
this is where i see who is in who is not
in so cvs he's done he bought at 88 he
has a stop loss at 86 not executed so
let's see why he got in new high nice
consolidation and a resistance
okay so indeed i see a nice
consideration before the move that is a
very good signal to use that's why i
added it guys
whenever you see this kind of
consolidation it means that the market
is building energy and usually uh you
need to wait for a breakout with volume
after this kind of consolidation before
getting in so here
g-star
is anticipating a breakout i guess
because i don't see a breakout all right
but i guess he has good reason to think
that we're going to have a breakout we
have something that is close to a
breakout
so for me i wouldn't get in right now he
has a stop loss at 86 so very tight okay
okay just below the
below friday's move which low was at
86.2 so i guess he's just using this so
he it's a day trading play which is
valid we had
we closed above so we have we had the
breakouts i mean
if you use the closing levels he could
see the breakout before so i understand
the move new high low okay because he's
considering that we traded above the
recent high here
and we closed above so this is true nice
consideration true and support
resistance uh okay i don't really
understand why he put support resistance
here i don't see a support so we have a
resistance that we are breaking out so
it's a breakout signal but whatever he's
in the trade let's see if he gets
stopped
where did he put his target
uh target at 91 okay so he's risking two
to win three so the risk reward is only
1.5 guys you know risking two to winning
three is not a beautiful risk reward uh
so the target is i think very much
achievable and he just used dalton high
all right
it's funny just above dalton high i
would personally put my selling order
here just below the all-time high right
because usually if we go slightly above
that we have a breakout but maybe he's
playing you know a fake out i don't know
anyway he is a number two in the ranking
but same he just entered his trade he's
basically making uh something close to
zero here then i'm gonna analyze uh as
we have only four plays i'm gonna go
through all of them the germans so uh we
have here a crypto player
so he wants to sell the bitcoin at 62
000 with a stop loss at 62 550.
so basically he got stopped because
bitcoin traded you can see i'm having
here the high bit concentrated at 63 700
at the highest level so basically he
sold here and bought
higher
so his trade has been closed with eddie
beeps loss but at least he's not losing
more that this is a tight stop loss it's
totally fair the reason was a support
resistance so do we have a resistance at
62
500 let's check on the hourly timeframe
okay
so let's let's see if there is some
support resistance at 62
okay here
got it
it's true we have here indeed a
resistance
that has been broken so he's saying
fibs
or supporter resistance
we indeed have uh the fib level at 62
hundred
sixty two thousand three hundred
so sometimes during abc corrections
because clearly guys we are in a
corrective mode on bitcoin and i think
he was playing a short b wave that then
got rejected uh before making new lows
uh but here the b wave was stronger than
i expected definitely we went to the
almost 61.8 percent
retracement so 50 61.8 something close
to that and now it seems that we are
again shifting south so let's see but he
got unfortunately stopped so he's losing
80 bips but as we gonna accumulate those
positions it's good guys to have a
strict risk management if you want to do
more plays so that you can still recover
from the losses if you make a loss at
the beginning of the month for next
month for example
then if you make good plays uh using a
stop loss for your first place is
something that can allow you to reach
the top three in the ranking and get
some price and the last is done by
context my thank uh it's a short trade
so basically let's have a look it's on
net he spotted a divergence and some
volumes that he used to short
at 182
with the target 165 so let's have a look
at that net all right
so he shorted
here and he's saying there is a
divergent so i don't see a divergence so
let's all right this stock is just going
higher if i need to do some ta this is
to me quite bullish here
okay i see a resistance but a bit higher
so i would not i think sell that early
but why not i mean this
this could have been valid i don't see
the divergence on the daily time frame
but i'm pretty sure there is one on a
shorter time frame and we have it indeed
but uh to me this divergence is not
strong enough we have market making
higher highs and macd making lower highs
but
you know for divergence to be really
valid we i like to have you know some
nice waves here i don't see really high
you know i just see a flattening of the
curve i like to see really like some
waves with real highs but maybe he's
gonna he's not he he didn't get stopped
he didn't use the stoppers right no stop
loss all right so maybe he's gonna come
back quickly the stock is moving a lot
so for now it didn't go in the right
direction but we still have the
divergence if he's looking at it in
terms of volume so maybe the volume are
shifting lower okay yeah that's it we
have the volumes going lower uh with the
price action going higher so indeed this
is a valid signal i like this kind of
play
it makes total total sense to check the
volumes and see
like if the bull the bulls are getting
tired all right if we're making new
highs with without momentum and without
volume usually there is a reversal so
it's very interesting for now display is
still valid we still have low volume we
still make new high but the volume
increased little bit so let's see i'm
not sure he would still do it right now
but the play is on uh in the simulation
that we are creating so
we're gonna keep following that and
let's see if he's able to uh come back
in the ranking and maybe beat chance or
g star for now chance is the number one
so congratulations to him once again for
now he's going to receive 300 us dollars
at the end of this week because we don't
have many players but next month the
prices will increase if we have more
players so guys come play if you are not
on discord yet join the fu area for now
i keep this game for the members the
paying members uh because we are
starting so we're still in the process
of building everything but i think we
will open it to the free area as well uh
maybe not next month but maybe the
months be later
so we're gonna have more players the
prices are gonna be bigger uh and the
purpose of this game is to show you guys
what kind of plays you do and then only
analyzing the best place that i see but
what is interesting is that you need to
give me some reasons some signals so i'm
gonna add more signals if i see that you
guys often use the other uh here signals
that you can have
if you don't know what signals to put
you can just put other signals so if i
see that many times i see the same i
will add it and i will use it maybe
myself as well it's a good way to learn
for you it might be even a way to learn
from me and i think it's very
entertaining to follow those plays at
least it is for me i hope it is for you
too
so i'm waiting for you guys come on
discord come to play and i'm gonna keep
updating you on everything that is
happening there so thank you very much
for watching this video and i see you
soon see you guys